we start again today with non-trump
stuff there is lots of news to discuss
and a blockbuster story about Supreme
Court Justice Clarence Thomas breaking
from propublica about his acceptance of
all sorts of high-value goodies from a
billionaire Republican possibly criminal
certainly unethical and we will discuss
it now we've had our suspicions about
Supreme Court Justice Clarence Thomas
not only did his tenure on the Supreme
Court start Under This Cloud of
allegation of sexual harassment we also
have seen this unbelievable story in
which he was presiding and potentially
presiding over cases related to the 2020
election as we knew that his wife Ginny
Thomas was an activist for the Biden
stole IT Crowd that was all wrapped up
and wide win in with the rioters of
January 6 2021. so and then you know 20
years in between that you can fill in
with other
red flags and question marks well there
has never been anything like this in
Supreme Court history in terms of
receiving gifts there's a fantastic
propublica piece that you can look at we
are going to look at a tweet thread from
propublica that gives us all of the most
important highlights and it starts for
decades judge Clarence Thomas Thomas has
secret secretly accepted luxury trips
from a major Republican donor newly
obtained documents show Thomas has
publicly presented presented himself as
an every man with modest tastes in this
documentary about him he waxes nostalgic
about his fondness for Walmart parking
lots but and this is one of those great
buts but Thomas's friendship with
dallas-based real estate magnate Harlan
Crowe has allowed him to repeatedly
experience luxuries well beyond his
means he's vacationed on Crow's 162 Foot
super yacht around the globe and flies
on Crows Bombardier Global 5000 jet
that's a nice jet nice jet if you can
get one in June of 2019 Thomas boarded
Crow's private jet to Indonesia for nine
days of island hopping on the yacht
had Thomas chartered the Jet and Yacht
himself could have set him back half a
million dollars it wasn't Thomas's first
time on Crow's yacht the Michaela Rose
he went on a river day in Savannah a
river day trip in Savannah Georgia and
an extended Cruise in New Zealand about
a decade ago while sailing around New
Zealand with Crow he autographed a copy
of his Memoir as a gift for a crew
member
by the way that that's quite a
narcissistic move thank you so much
here's my book the justice has gone with
Crow to the Bohemian Grove the exclusive
California all-male retreat and to
Crow's sprawling Texas ranch every
summer Thomas typically spends about a
week at Camp Top Ridge Crow's private
Resort in the Adirondacks inside the top
Ridge hangs a photorealistic painting of
one of Thomas's visits to the property
the painting shows Thomas enjoying a
cigar alongside Crow and chatting with
conservative power Brokers like Leonard
Leo if Leo's name sounds familiar it's
because the longtime Federalist Society
executive is regarded as an architect of
the Supreme Court's turn to the right
and recently received 1.6 billion
dollars for a new conservative political
group wow what Brazen cronyism and
Corruption
uh this continues and you can read all
of it uh I think the the important part
here is as follows
while Thomas and Crow have a genuine
friendship these vacations put the
Justice in contact with corporate
Executives and political activists
during just one July 2017 trip Thomas's
fellow guests included Executives at
Verizon
pricewaterhousecoopers major Republican
donors one of the leaders of the
conservative American Enterprise
Institute these trips appear nowhere on
Thomas's Financial disclosures where
justices are required to list most gifts
this is where we start to get into
potential criminality Pro publica looked
at flight records internal documents and
interviews with dozens of people to
uncover the travel details the failure
to report the flights appears to violate
a federal disclosure law passed after
Watergate by accepting the trips Thomas
has also broken on standing norms for
judges conduct ethics experts say
Nancy gertner a retired federal judge
says it's incomprehensible to me that
someone would do this Virginia cantor a
former government ethics lawyer who has
served in administrations of both
parties says Thomas quote seems to have
completely disregarded his higher
ethical obligations Thomas did not
respond to detailed questions so without
question this corrupts public trust and
justices are supposed to abide by a
higher ethical obligation in which not
only should you avoid
actual bias and partiality you should
avoid even the appearance of it
and there are a couple of different
stories here one is that Clarence Thomas
and his wife have a long history of
political entanglements with absolutely
no accountability we've known that for a
long time
secondly we have another Law and Order
story where my guess is and we'll have
to wait and see my guess is that right
Wingers will immediately Rush with
knee-jerk reactions to defend Clarence
Thomas and say these are paperwork
crimes just like Trump saw paperwork
crimes and everybody's all paperwork
crimes or whatever the case may be so
there will be no uh consistency there
and then lastly
is Clarence Thomas like this desperate
to be participating in this sort of
stuff that like it almost feels like you
know a yacht cruise and a trap to some
degree it all seems kind of pathetic as
well but now going from just the
suspicion of lack of Ethics to what
seems like bona fide a criminality the
violations of law as re as it regards
these Financial disclosures will it go
anywhere I don't know with Clarence
Clarence Thomas has had a sort of Teflon
status quo much like Donald Trump did
for many years although hopefully the
latter is ending with this week's arrest
that's the latest really great report uh
from propublica